[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Good afternoon.
I'm Tomiko Brown-Nagin,
the dean of the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study.
I'm delighted to welcome all of
you to today's panel discussion
on the 2018 midterm elections.
This program is part of
the Davis Lecture series,
established by Kim
and Judy Davis,
to feature leading thinkers
and artists in public talks.
I'm glad to see Kim
Davis in the audience.
Thank you for your
support, as always.
I'm also grateful to members
of the Radcliffe Institute
Leadership Society, and to all
of our dedicated annual donors
who are here this afternoon.
Thank you very much.
Today, we're exactly
four weeks out
from the most anticipated
midterm elections
in recent memory.
The stakes were high.
Besides all 435 seats in the
House of Representatives,
the polls decided 35
seats in the Senate,
governorships in 36 states,
ballot measures in 37 states,
and thousands of state
legislative seats
and local races.
The outcomes of the
midterms has a bearing
on political
representation, on policy,
on many facets of daily
life and local communities,
and on the civic climate
and the political landscape
of our nation at large.
While the results are in,
with a few exceptions--
[CHUCKLING]
Yes.
Answers to some of
the big questions
will take time to emerge.
Questions like,
what do the midterms
mean for American politics,
for American society?
What do they mean for policy
in the immediate term,
and for years to come?
Was the election
a turning point?
Put another way, to what
extent and in what areas
do these midterms tell a
story of fundamental change,
or a story of continuity?
Our speakers this
afternoon will explore
some of these questions,
and many other questions,
as they put the midterm
results in context.
They'll also focus our attention
on the roles of new voters,
and the results for candidates
and elected officials
from historically
underrepresented groups,
including women,
people of color,
religious minorities,
immigrants,
and the LGBTQ community.
We do know that history
was made in many races.
In House contest, an
unprecedented number of women
ran, and they won.
Come January, for the
first time in history,
the house will have more than
100 women representatives.
Yes.
[APPLAUSE]
And yet, men still outnumber
women in Congress by a 3 to 1
ratio.
Many of the House races
were historic from
an intersectional perspective.
Among the 40 or so women
who will take their seats
in the House of Representatives
for the first time in January
are the first two Native
women elected to Congress,
the first two
Muslim women elected
to Congress, the first two
Latinas elected to Congress
from Texas, the first openly
gay representative of Kansas,
and the first
African-American woman
to represent the Commonwealth
of Massachusetts.
You can applaud for that too.
[APPLAUSE]
Beyond the House
of Representatives,
Marsha Blackburn of Tennessee
and Cindy Hyde-Smith
of Mississippi became
the first women
elected to represent their
states in the US Senate.
And Jared Polis
of Colorado became
the country's first
openly gay governor,
as well as the first
Jewish governor of a state.
In Florida, voters approved
a ballot initiative
that restores the right
to vote to more than 1
million Floridians with
prior felony convictions.
- Woo!
- Yes.
[APPLAUSE]
But the story, as
ever, is complex.
At the same time as we
witness historic wins
and the restoration of
voting rights to some,
voters in North
Carolina and Arkansas
passed constitutional
amendments that
will require photo IDs
in order to cast ballots
in future elections.
Thus, we saw both expansion and
contraction of the franchise.
Historic firsts
are important for
a diverse and
representative democracy,
even though we know
that firsts are not
sufficient to undo gender and
racial disparities, wealth
inequality, voter suppression,
and the many systemic barriers
to achieving
opportunity and justice.
Thus, the celebration
of firsts only
scratches the surface of
today's ambitious topic,
the meaning of the midterms.
In a moment, I'll
turn things over
to Asma Khalid, who
I'm delighted to have
here today as our moderator.
Asma is a political
reporter for NPR.
She is known for clear,
sensitive, and insightful
reporting on American
voters and the shifting
political landscape in
the US through the lenses
of demographics and economics.
In recent months,
weeks, and days,
Asma has brought that
expertise and insight
to the 2018 midterms.
She also covered the 2016
presidential campaign for NPR.
Before that, Asma covered tech,
business, and economic issues
here in Boston at WBUR.
Asma got her start in journalism
in her home state of Indiana.
She decided to become
a reporter when
she was just seven years old.
Among many honors, Asma received
the University of Missouri
Honor Medal for Distinguished
Service in Journalism
just last year.
I'm grateful to
her for joining us,
and she'll introduce the panel.
Thank you all for
being here, and I
hope to see you at
Radcliffe again soon.
If you're interested
in continuing
to explore
contemporary politics,
you can join us next week
on Wednesday, December
12 at 4:00 PM for a
talk by Radcliffe Fellow
and Yale Professor Jacob
Hacker on right-wing populism
in the US.
And now, please join me in
warmly welcoming Asma Khalid
to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
- So thank you all
so much for coming.
It's such a delight to see
so many people who are still
excited to talk
about the midterms,
because, candidly,
I think some of us
feel like we've been in
this rut of reporting
on the midterms
for so many months.
But I think there are
still lots of lessons
to learn from what happened
in 2018 that might give us
a glimpse into what
we can try to decipher
about the next presidential
election in 2020.
So thank you again.
My name is Asma Khalid, and
I'm a political reporter
with National Public Radio.
During the campaign
cycle that just passed,
I was one of our chief
political correspondents.
And that meant I traveled
across the country,
criss-crossing the
country many places,
trying to figure out what
was motivating voters,
and what was also motivating
some of the candidates
that those voters
were selecting.
For me, as a
reporter who focuses
a lot on voters
and demographics,
I just want to quickly give us
a sense of three big takeaways.
And then I will
introduce our panel,
who will talk in a lot more
depth about all of this.
So the three big,
what I would call
essential takeaways
of the midterms
was, number one,
voter turnout was up.
We really reached, actually,
rather historic levels
of turnout this election
cycle that we had not
seen since World War II.
Still, though, a majority of
eligible voters did not vote.
And when you say that in
slow language, you're like,
wow, a majority of the eligible
voting population did not vote.
I think what we want to
focus on lessons learned
from what this might
mean-- because we did
have some Democratic candidates,
particularly in Georgia
and in Texas, who really
tried to galvanize
these non-traditional voters
in a midterm election cycle.
And undoubtedly,
you're going to see
Democratic candidates
in 2020 also
try to mobilize this base
of the Democratic Party.
Number two, we saw an increasing
split along education lines.
Among the 15 most
highly-educated congressional
districts in the country--
including yours truly, this
district right here that we all
live in--
not one is currently
represented or will
be currently represented in the
new Congress by a Republican.
What I find rather astounding
about all of this is,
we don't need to
go very far back--
we could go just to the '90s--
and we had many of these
highly-educated districts
represented by
Republicans at a time when
George HW Bush was
the Republican Party
standard-bearer.
But as I said, two
districts in particular--
a suburban district
outside of Georgia,
and another suburban district
in northern Virginia--
which had been
represented by Republicans
now will be both
represented by Democrats.
And to me, this is a really
interesting new change
that we saw that may give us
a glimpse, again, into 2020.
And lastly, as the
dean just mentioned,
this was undoubtedly a huge
year for Democratic women.
And I'm sure that we will
talk a lot more about this,
and what this means,
but there were really
women that I met throughout
my reporting cycle
this year who told
me they had never
been involved in a campaign
cycle prior to 2018.
They were now knocking on doors.
They were volunteering
for candidates.
And these were women who,
prior to this election cycle,
perhaps may have just voted.
That was the extent of
their political engagement.
So we're going to talk a
lot more about all of this,
and many other, also, lessons
that all of our panelists have.
And to help us do that,
we've got a panel that I just
want to quickly introduce.
Immediately to my left
here is Aimee Allison.
She's the president of Democracy
in Color, a really interesting
organization.
Aimee and I candidly actually
have spoken on the phone
a couple of times
in my reporting,
but just now had the
opportunity to meet in person.
Then we have Sarah Lenti, who's
a board member of Serve America
Movement and a
political consultant
to what I believe is
center-right Republicans
at this point.
Then we have Katharine
Cramer, who's
a professor of political science
at the University of Wisconsin,
Madison, and the
author of a book
that you all might be
familiar with called
The Politics of Resentment,
which was about politics
in rural areas of Wisconsin.
And then all the way
down to our left,
we have Robert Self, a
professor of American history
at Brown University.
So I will let the
panelists kick it off,
and we'll begin
with Aimee Allison.
[APPLAUSE]
- Yay.
Good afternoon, everyone.
It's such a pleasure to
be here, and thank you
so much for the organizers,
dean, the professors,
and for the community, for
welcoming this conversation,
I just want to say one thing.
Women of color won the midterms.
[APPLAUSE]
I wrote an op-ed
a week and a half
ago in the San Francisco
Chronicle, where I come from,
making that assertion.
But before that--
long before that--
the story, for me,
about women of color
begins a year and a half ago.
I was there in Albany, Georgia
when Stacey Abrams declared
her candidacy for governor.
She would be the first
black woman governor
ever in our history, and
certainly in the Deep South.
Her campaign was
exciting from the get-go.
Here was a woman who
was a fantastic leader.
She was a woman who was already
a House leader, Democrats,
the House minority leader, with
a broad-based social justice,
progressive agenda.
She also recognized
something about Georgia
that most Democrats and the
public at large did not know.
That Georgia, in
a couple of years,
will be majority
people of color.
It wasn't just a
black-and-white state.
It was a rainbow
there in Georgia.
And that 40% of registered
Democrats were black women.
She recognized black
women were the core
and the most loyal
and important voting
bloc of the Democratic Party.
She recognized
something else too.
Even though white Democrats--
including Jason Carter,
President Jimmy
Carter's grandson--
had run for statewide
office, he was only
able to capture 23% of the
white vote in that state.
Many of these Democrats ran on a
very moderate, centrist agenda,
and yet they were
never able to win.
In the last 10 years, there
hasn't been a statewide victory
of Democrats in Georgia.
And yet Stacey Abrams
knew something else.
She looked at the electorate,
and she recognized
that there were 1.2 million
eligible unregistered people
of color, not just in Atlanta,
but throughout the state,
including the rural part
of southern Georgia,
known as the Black Belt. When
she declared her candidacy
in southern Georgia, she
was making a statement right
from the Black Belt,
which was this.
Instead of stacking
millions like most
gubernatorial
candidates, right away,
she had two dozen
organizers going
on every part of the state,
rural, suburban, and urban,
registering and
talking to voters.
Now, the Democratic
Party, of which
she helped by expanding
the electorate in her time
before she declared candidacy
by founding this organization
called the New
Georgia Project that
was registering new voters.
But the Democratic
Party did not believe
a black woman could win.
And so they cynically recruited
a white moderate millionaire
married woman named
Stacey Evans to run
in the primary
against Stacey Abrams.
Now, the party believed that
the most important voters to win
were moderate white
voters in Georgia.
And so Stacey Abrams
reached out specifically
to all these
different communities,
and at the end of the primary--
which resulted in
a landslide where
she won all but four counties
throughout the state--
the turnout for black
women was through the roof,
for black voters.
But the Latina turnout--
Latinx turnout--
was up three times,
and the Asian-American
turnout was up six times
over the last midterms.
So what I argued was
that Stacey Abrams
knew something the Democratic
Party needed to learn.
It was a new playbook that
recognized who is in the party.
That the party nationally
was half people
of color and a quarter black.
And that black women
and women of color
were the most
progressive at the polls.
They were also the most likely
to be primaried by people
in their own party,
and they were also
those who were promoting the
strongest social justice,
racial, economic justice
agenda in this country.
And on top of that,
women of color
were the best strategists
for this new playbook
of expanding the electorate.
Now, I've been in politics
a number of years,
and I've seen a
lot of campaigns.
And the big mistake
that I believe
happened that we saw with
the Clinton campaign in 2016
that Stacey Abrams
was attempting
to correct in the
midterms was deeply
investing in the most
progressive voters
and expanding the electorate.
Instead of spending millions
on TV ads-- which, by the way,
don't get people to the polls--
she was investing on the ground,
people knocking on doors,
and meeting people
where they were.
Now, you might have read
that it didn't work out
with the prize
for Stacey Abrams.
At the time, as a
longtime consultant
in her campaign, who
spent a lot of time
in Georgia with her
campaign and got
to see what it was like on the
ground, the voter suppression,
the way that, institutionally,
she ran against an opponent,
it's like playing a
football game where
your opponent is the referee.
And she had to face an
insurmountable series of voter
suppression techniques,
and ultimately
wasn't able to gain the prize
as the first black woman.
But she cracked the code.
Originally thought, hey, I
need a little over 200,000
additional Democratic
Party votes
in order to win
the state, and she
delivered 800,000 additional.
So what's happened?
It's amazing what she did.
So you can lose and win.
Because if we look at the
lesson for the midterms,
when it comes to
Stacey Abrams, you
see how close the Democrats
got to capturing the big prize
despite the challenges.
So when I say women of
color won the midterms,
it's not just the incredible
firsts of the new members
of Congress, the
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez--
who's very cool on Instagram,
if you're not following her
stories--
who's opening up, and really,
for the country to see,
what is it like to be on-boarded
as a new Congress person?
What's it like for her?
And she is making it more
accessible as the youngest
member of Congress ever,
the political process.
It's not just Deb
Haaland from New Mexico,
or Rashida Tlaib from Michigan.
It's that all of these women,
after 2016, decided to serve.
They were coming from
movements, and not one of them
was backed in the primary by the
Democratic Party, like Stacey.
Right here in your own
home state, Ayanna Presley,
incoming Congresswoman.
The thing that people
don't understand
about her and her leadership
is that she inspired
a whole new set of voters.
52% of the people who voted for
Ayanna Presley were new voters.
So what we're seeing,
and one of the lessons
that I desperately need people
to understand, particularly
around the Democratic
Party and why
there was such success at
the polls when there hadn't
been in 2016 and years past.
We're at an inflection
point in this country.
We're almost majority
of people of color.
And as I said with a group
of students earlier today,
there's no majority,
and there's no minority.
And the primacy of voters,
who is invested in,
what the candidates look like,
what the issues they carry,
need to change in
order to inspire
the population of
our country as is.
And that future is multiracial.
And women of color are
at the leading edge
of inspiring a multiracial
coalition that I
believe will win in 2020.
Now, today in Politico,
there was an article,
the first one that
acknowledged that women--
black women in particular--
will be the main vote picking
the presidential primary
candidate.
And that was never
acknowledged before.
So I founded She the
People earlier this year
as the first-ever
organization focused
on solidifying the political
voice of women of color
as voters, as leaders,
as movement leaders,
and as strategists who
are defending democracy
and providing a really inspiring
solution for the country.
And in my last, I
had a big summit
that brought together 600
women in San Francisco,
100,000 on livestream, and some
really great women on stage.
A woman named Elmaz
Abinader wrote a poem.
She called it "Anthem for Now,"
and I'll read two stanzas.
"Hear this.
Country, you do not need
a telescope to find us.
Stars are among you.
Shift your eyes from the
corridors to the sky,
from the sky to the home,
from the home to the field,
from the field to the classroom,
hospital, factory floor,
and street corner.
Hear this.
We are the voiceless,
and we will be heard.
Not as a song to entertain you,
not as a rule to be followed,
or a call to dinner.
We call on you to
listen to the voices
that stream in from embattled
countries and towns with names
hard to pronounce and
ways you do not see on TV.
The world inside and
beside me are one.
Change starts when you
listen to the heart."
So I'd finally
say, women of color
who showed such incredible
power at the polls
in the midterms I
believe will lead,
because they're leading
with love and justice,
to create a country
of belonging.
And that's what we
so desperately need.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Great presentation.
Thank you.
OK.
It's great to be
here with you today.
I want to take this time to
forecast a little upon what
the midterm results
may mean for President
Trump, the GOP, and 2020.
Why the GOP focus?
I started out in
Republican politics
under Condi Rice,
one of the greats,
and I left the party in
2016 because of the obvious.
As such, I'm keenly
interested in what's happening
to the GOP, so let's review.
The GOP lost the
midterms by roughly 9%.
2018 goes down as the highest
midterm turnout in 50 years,
with 49% of the voting
population casting votes
because they were angry
and highly motivated.
There were some interesting
results across the states
that I quickly want to
review, because I think
it reflects on the president.
Consider that in
Iowa, during 2016,
there wasn't a day when Trump
wasn't ahead in the polls.
On November 6,
the GOP lost three
of four congressional
seats in that state.
Pennsylvania.
In 2016, Trump won
with 44,000 votes.
The midterms came.
The GOP lost four
congressional seats.
In 2016, in Arizona,
Trump won by 91,000 votes.
The midterms came.
The GOP lost a Senate seat
and a Congressional seat.
And that was not supposed to
happen, by the GOP's terms.
So the GOP suffered major losses
across the country this cycle,
and particularly in
the suburbs with women.
With that said, we
learned some things
about the increasing
Trumpification
of the Republican base.
Let's look at the
shifting ideology
and rhetoric of the GOP first.
Russia.
Since when have
conservative Republicans
advocated for a softer approach
to Putin or Russia itself?
Yeah, I studied this
in graduate school,
and it's not in my lifetime.
So immigration.
Republicans went from advocating
for comprehensive immigration
reform under George W. Bush to
now supporting a massive wall
and being OK with family
separation at the border.
What about the base's
new take on trade?
These new and
shifting ideologies
are a reflection of
the president himself.
Some would argue that the
pro-Trump Republican base isn't
growing.
This may be the
case, but I would
argue that it's hardening, and
we know this from the midterms.
That is, Republicans
who chose not
to align with
President Trump in 2018
lost in places that were
Republican strongholds.
Asma, you mentioned northern
Virginia and Barbara Comstock,
Virginia 10.
This was a seat the
Republicans held
for 60 of the last 66 years.
No longer.
Mike Coffman, near me
in Denver, Colorado.
10 years in a
conservative enclave.
Lost district 6.
Mia Love in Utah.
Need I say more?
So even if the president's
base is stagnant,
it is also radical,
and it's hardening.
And what I want
to convey here is
that despite the fact
that Democrats just
won the midterms, the president
could be re-elected in 2020.
So what am I basing
this statement on?
The facts and history.
Fact, the average midterm pickup
for a party out of power is 33.
Democrats just succeeded that.
And now let's hone in
on which side's won big
in the last 40-plus years.
Democrats in '72,
'82, '06, and '08.
Republicans in '94 and '10.
And the result of
these big midterm wins?
Nothing with respect
to the presidency.
So let me repeat,
midterm results
have little to no
bearing on the upcoming
presidential elections.
OK.
So what does matter?
If midterm election
results are not
predictive of presidential
election results, what is?
Historically, data shows
us that approval ratings
are the key indicators
for incumbent presidents.
And more specifically,
a president or party
needs to maintain a base
approval rating of 40%
to tip an incumbent presidential
candidate toward success.
And you'll see that as
you move from 40% to 50%,
it increases dramatically
the likelihood of a win.
Some of you are hearing
this 40% threshold
and shaking your head,
thinking, this can't apply.
But we have to slow
down and recall
that President Obama had similar
numbers around his midterm
elections and won.
I personally entered
this analysis
thinking that President Trump is
just too partisan for anything
historic to apply, but-- and
I did this with the assumption
being that the more
partisan the president,
the closer the president's
approval rating
would be to zero amongst the
opposing party or independents.
And that's just not the case.
The data shows us that
even amongst the opposing
party and independents, approval
ratings for President Obama
and President Trump with
the opposing parties
were similar at around 10%.
And then for the opposing
party, between 36% and 40%
for independents.
Just a snapshot of where the
president was at Halloween.
And then where he
was at November 14.
Post midterms, post the
caravan, post deploying troops
to the border, his numbers
inched up incrementally
from 41% to 43%, which,
to me, was shocking.
Moving on, I want
to present to you
a poll that was taken
by the Tarrance Group.
And this poll sampled 800
likely 2020 voters before
and after the midterms in
pivot counties across the US.
The poll asked voters, if
the 2020 presidential were
to occur today, would you
vote for President Donald
Trump, the Democratic nominee,
or some other candidate?
The result, the president
won before the midterms,
and he won after the midterms.
But to me, what's
interesting here is
the 25% bloc of voters
who were either leaning
towards an independent
after the midterm,
or undecided in their vote.
Combined, this is a
potentially-powerful bloc
that could influence 2020.
And further, we don't know how
this bloc would shift the vote
with the entry of a credible
independent candidate that
could self-fund, or that
would just be funded,
who's able to peel off some
soft Republicans and Democrats.
And most will say,
this can't be done.
And we can look
to Perot on this.
Perhaps.
But there is a very
specific scenario in polling
that has been done
suggesting that if you have
extreme candidates coming
out of the primary,
a la Trump on the right,
or progressive Sanders
or Warren on the left, you
have a window for a more
moderate independent candidate.
And I think there's some
interesting data here.
And this is the group of voters
that went from 10% to 16%
after the midterms saying
that they were undecided.
And I want to look at who
was left feeling undecided
after that vote.
Southeastern and
Mountain-Pacific voters,
unemployed male voters, employed
voters, male college graduates,
soft GOP, unmarried
men, dads, single women,
and the 55-and-over group.
So we know a lot about
the post-midterm analysis.
And Aimee, you focused
on the women demographic,
and it is critical.
I totally agree.
But we have to be honest.
Some of this data suggests
that the male vote is something
that we have to contend
with, and continue
to contend with as well.
Quickly, I just want to touch
on a few things, on the issues.
It was surprising in
this election cycle.
It was health care
and immigration.
And probably not a
surprise, Democrats
carried with the
health care narrative.
President Trump was forcing
the immigration debate.
But one thing that Democrats,
Republicans, and independents
are in solid agreement
upon was this.
The political system is broken.
And that extends
beyond the presidency.
It touches the
primary system, how
Congress functions,
dark money in politics,
and government writ large.
And the main takeaway from
some polling that Ipsos--
a research firm-- did was
that, in this election,
restoring trust and civility
was a far greater importance
than the issues itself.
So why are we desirous
of trust and civility?
Because today, the trust in our
political parties is at 18%.
We are experiencing
increased tribalization.
This graphic depicts where the
two parties and independents
are on perhaps the most
contentious and polarizing
issue from 1972 to
today, abortion.
Over time, there were
moments when the groups
were closer together.
But today, they're farther
apart than we've ever seen.
Finally, what does
this tribalization
mean for people and for
our own relationships?
I think we all have anecdotes
where people have defriended
people because of
what they're saying
about this party or the other.
There was a poll conducted
in August of 2017
asking people from
the two parties
who they consider to
be a real American.
And sadly, today, we're so
polarized that Democrats
and Republicans are
increasingly prone to not view
each other as, quote-unquote,
real Americans.
And if you believe
that immigration
should be restricted, you're
not a real American to some.
And if you believe that
black lives matter,
you're not a real
American to some.
To me, this is not only
sad, it's dangerous,
and it begs for a unifier who
can restore trust and civility.
And so that's what
I'm waiting for,
and we'll see what
happens in 2020.
Sorry to depress.
[APPLAUSE]
- So it's my honor to be
with you this afternoon,
and I'm going to pick up where
Sarah left off, because I
share these concerns as well.
And I think those results
about so many people
being very focused on the
lack of trust and civility,
and being more
concerned about that
than any specific issue is a
really important data point
that we need to
pay attention to.
I've been very interested
in the geographic divides
that we're experiencing
in this country.
And so my research over
the past decade or so
has been focused on
the so-called rural
versus urban
divide, and so I was
interested in the outcomes of
these midterms with respect
to that.
And sure enough,
we definitely saw
that our bluer areas, or our
more Democratic urban areas,
became more Democratic, and
our rural or small towns
became even more Republican.
That's a broad brush to paint,
and really, a lot of people
will point to the suburbs as
the big story in this election.
And that was a really
interesting case in point
in which we saw a
deepening of divides.
In other words, the suburbs
kind of sorting out.
And so, for example, you saw,
of the 40 Democratic gains
and seats in the House,
most of those seats
came from majority-suburban
districts.
And in particular, we saw
white college-educated women
leaning toward the
Democratic Party
at rates that were unusual with
respect to recent elections.
And so for me, the
outcome of this midterm
reinforces the divides that
we're experiencing with respect
to geography.
And that's important, because
it's not just a correlation.
It's not just people moving
to a place that corresponds
with their partisanship.
But instead, I've seen
through my own fieldwork
that, in fact, it's oftentimes
a deep cultural divide in which
people are making
sense of politics
through lenses that are
rooted in their identity
as a person of a
certain type of place.
So for example, what I
heard in Wisconsin when
I was doing fieldwork along
the lines of inviting myself
into conversations with
regularly-occurring groups
of people, I heard people
in these smaller towns just
resenting what they saw
as more attention, more
resources, and more respect
going to the cities.
And they were
making those claims
on the basis of people
who saw themselves
as small-town, or rural folks.
I would say there's an upside,
though, to these midterms.
And that is that
intense engagement
that we saw in
the turnouts where
the turnout rates were quite
astounding, as Asma was saying.
And that's an upside.
Any time we see more
engagement in our democracy,
I guess you could
say is an upside.
But there's a
downside to that too,
in that much of that engagement
was driven by people feeling
as though their voices
were not being heard,
and that politics was out of
step, that the political system
was broken.
And so in many respects, we
see a lot of different people
saying that they're left
out of the conversation.
Feeling or expressing that
their lives are very removed
from the public conversation.
And I'll give you one example
from my fieldwork in Wisconsin.
That when I go to
these small towns, even
groups of people who
supported Donald Trump, who
voted for Donald Trump, and I
ask them, so which party better
represents the interests
of people around here?
Without skipping a beat,
more often than not,
they say neither.
Neither party represents
people like me.
And folks in
small-town Wisconsin
aren't the only ones saying
that around the country.
And that feeling
of being removed
from the public conversation
is pretty important,
and pretty depressing.
However, at this
point, I guess I
would like to move my remarks
from being one of an academic
to one of a practitioner.
Because as I, like many of
you, have looked around me
and thought about, how
do I best use my talents
at this point in time to try
to make this a better democracy
for all of us?
By chance, I met someone
who's become a dear
friend and a collaborator
who's with us
today, Deb Roy, who's
a scientist at MIT.
He runs the Laboratory
for Social Machines
at the MIT Media Lab.
And Deb and I met by chance,
actually, at a conference
here at Harvard.
And Deb approached me and
asked me about my background.
And he basically
said, what would it
take to scale up the listening
that you did so that we could
better understand what people
think about in the public,
and so that people in the
public could have a chance
to listen to one another, to
better understand one another?
And so through a
series of conversations
and through working with
the amazing group of people
he has at his lab, the
Laboratory for Social Machines,
and this nonprofit
organization that they've
created to disseminate the
great things that they create--
and that nonprofit's
called Cortico--
we're starting an
experiment in about a month
in Madison, Wisconsin.
We're running a pilot experiment
of a project called the Local
Voices Network in which
we're drawing together
small groups of people
in conversations
run by facilitators who
are themselves volunteers
from the community.
And the conversation
will be based on a script
that we've developed over
time which asks people
basic open-ended
questions about,
what are they concerned about?
What are they hopeful about?
What brought them
to their community?
What do they want others
to know about their lives?
And so through the
conversations themselves,
people will have a chance
to listen to one another.
But the team at Deb's
lab and at Cortico
has developed a
piece of hardware
that will enable the
facilitators to actually import
comments from other
conversations going on, right
now, in other parts of Madison.
But ideally, down
the line, as we
expand into other communities,
from other types of places.
So the facilitator will be
able to stop the conversation
and say, let's
reflect for a moment
on a bit of a conversation
that took place last week
in such-and-such place.
And I'd like you all to
think about what insights you
get from hearing this person.
And through those conversations,
then-- which will be recorded--
there's a creation
of a dashboard that
will enable people to see
what other people are talking
about, to see the transcripts
of what people said,
and to hear for
themselves the words
of their fellow residents,
whether that be right
there in Madison or in
other parts of the state,
or in other parts
of the country.
And we're hoping that
this is one way in which--
that we can make something
different of the divides
that we're experiencing.
We're not naive to think that
our partisan leanings are not
deeply rooted.
But what we're hoping for
is that people have a chance
to see the nuance in each
other, as opposed to just seeing
red, or blue, or
Democrat, or Republican,
or whatever divide you
want to talk about.
We think that there
is a need for nuance,
and there's a need
for listening,
and there's a need to recognize
that there are many of us
who wish to be heard.
So thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
- Good afternoon.
I am really
delighted and humbled
to be on this panel with
Aimee, Kathy, Sarah, and Asma.
I can't imagine a
more insightful cohort
of expert activists.
My role this afternoon
is to step back a bit
from the 2018 midterm
elections and suggest
some profitable historical
contexts in which we
might profitably place them.
And I'll offer three
with no pretense
of being comprehensive,
but in the spirit
of the session's title,
"Who Counted, Who Voted."
The three perspectives
are, first,
voter suppression and the
making of an electorate.
Second, gender gaps in voting.
And third, coalitions and
dominant political paradigms
in America since the 1930s.
My hope is to make one
or two clear points
about each of those to build on
the insights of my colleagues.
So first, let's talk
about voter suppression
and the construction
of the electorate.
In the simplest terms,
people in the United States
have fought over access
to the ballot since 1787.
The earliest exclusions--
perhaps too obviously--
included anyone not white,
male, and property-owning.
From that beginning,
pushes for enfranchisement
and disfranchisement came
together in successive waves.
Property-less white
men were enfranchised
in the first half of the
19th century at the same time
that most states eliminated
alien or non-citizen voting.
The 15th Amendment enfranchised
black men after the Civil War,
but widespread
suppression quickly
followed, especially in
the former Confederacy,
with systematic
disenfranchisement
coming a few decades later.
Native people were excluded
explicitly from their franchise
until 1924.
The 19th Amendment enfranchised
women by Constitutional mandate
in 1920, but was silent on
the forms of disfranchisement
that prevented the poor
and non-white from voting.
A list of laws and practices
running pages in length.
Among those who could legally
vote, some votes counted more.
Until the 17th Amendment
was ratified in 1913,
there was no direct
election of senators.
Choosing them by popular vote
was a democratic advancement,
but it still gave the
citizens of rural states
disproportionate
power in Congress
and the Electoral
College compared
with their counterparts
in urban states.
Moreover, until the one
person, one vote Supreme Court
decisions of the
1960s, most states
awarded rural areas
significantly-disproportionate
political representation in
their state legislatures.
The Voting Rights
Act came in 1965,
as you know, alongside
the 14th, 15th
19th, and 26th
Constitutional amendments.
The 26th is the one that
set the voting age at 18.
The Voting Rights Act
of '65 is the foundation
of modern voting.
But the Supreme Court's gutting
of the law in the Shelby County
decision in 2013 opened the
door to a new generation of laws
and practices aimed at targeted
voter suppression, enacted
almost exclusively by Republican
state legislatures and states
attorney general that played
a major role in this election.
I need not remind you that race
in particular, and also age,
have been central to
these new efforts.
The electorate is dramatically
changing, as Aimee introduced
this panel by suggesting.
It's changing with the
country's demographics.
We can see this just in looking
at the representation in 1992
and 2016 that I
have provided here.
And if we just
isolate race, we can
see the ways in which
demographics and the voter
identification are
shifting dramatically.
Overall, in the
nation, white voters
are declining dramatically
as a share of the electorate.
Given this history,
it's not surprising
that among nations
with free elections,
the US sits near the bottom
of voter participation
as a percentage of
age-eligible voters.
This brief history condenses
into a few basic points.
The electorate is not a
natural or organic entity.
It is brought into being by
law, culture, and practice.
Since 1787, struggles
over who could vote
and how much their vote
counted have never abated.
But the Shelby County
decision in 2013,
together with
demographic changes,
have intensified the politics
of electoral construction
and management,
which we can expect
to play an ever-larger
role in US politics
in the next few decades.
If voter suppression
emerged as a major tactic
in the 2018 elections, let
me turn to a second issue.
The combined energy of
several developments
raised anew the question
of whether and how women
vote differently from
men, a phenomenon
simplified by journalists
as the gender gap.
Journalistic observations
of a gender gap in voting
date to 1964, the year of Lyndon
Johnson's Democratic landslide.
And, by the way, the
last national election
in which a Democratic candidate
won the majority of white men.
The gap was small-- the
gender gap-- mostly between 5%
and 10%, and always
found women choosing
Democratic
presidential candidates
at higher rates than men.
It exploded in the 1990s,
and with the exception
of the early 2000s, has
remained in the teens and 20s
since then.
Here's a graphic
representation of that gender
gap in presidential, and I
believe midterm elections
as well.
The gap is important,
and worth our attention.
But as a single metric, it
obscures as much as it reveals.
Its pretense is that half
the voting age population
of a nation of more
than 300 million people
can be described by a
single category of identity.
If we disaggregated
even a little,
more illuminating
aspects emerge.
For one, the divergence
of party identification
between women and
men is astonishingly
high among people under 40.
Further disaggregation
here is needed by race.
And as we do that, we see that
African-American and Latinx
women, by and large, are
voting in enormous numbers
and percentages for Democratic
candidates in both 2016
and 2018 overwhelmingly.
So if we disaggregate
the gender gap by race,
it's clear that it's also
and importantly a racial gap.
Again, this is something that
Aimee stressed in her opening
remarks.
What can we conclude from this?
Women vote in higher
absolute numbers
and at a higher rate than men.
According to the Center for
American Women and Politics,
9.9 million more women
than men voted in 2016.
Overall, the gender
gap in voting--
with a few exceptions-- has run
between 12% and 22% since 1994.
Within that, there is a
substantial racial gap
among women, with
black and Latinx voters
choosing Democrats by
24 to 43 percentage
points above white women.
If voter suppression
and the gender gap both
emerged as prominent narratives
in the 2014 midterms,
my final historical
subject did not.
This is quite unlike
2018, where there
was a great deal of media
chatter about whether the Obama
election represented an
electoral realignment.
But the Democratic
Congressional surge of 2010,
the rise of the Tea Party,
and the election of Trump
quieted those
speculations decisively.
If Obama's election
did not usher
in a new dominant
political coalition,
how do we think about
our present moment?
As I've argued elsewhere,
we can identify
three major political
syntheses in the last 80 years
in the United States.
Two were once
dominant in the sense
that they shaped the terms
of political contest,
gave us our language
of political culture,
and defined the policy horizons.
The third was-- and is--
powerful enough to be
meaningful, but not
enough to structure the
political system as a whole.
None of the three, at
present, is ascendant.
The first is what I call
breadwinner liberalism,
a center-left convergence of
ideologies and policy around
investing in the human capital
of and creating a safety net
for heterosexual male
breadwinner nuclear families,
largely--
though we should not say
entirely-- exclusively white.
This political synthesis emerged
during the Great Depression,
was primarily the work
of the Democratic Party,
and gave structure and
content to national politics
until roughly the 1970s.
It was displaced by what I
call breadwinner conservatism.
Breadwinner conservatism
was a right-wing synthesis
that sometimes flirted with a
center-right moderation that
seized upon the heterosexual
male breadwinner
nuclear family, but reversed
its ideological terms.
The nuclear family required
moral, not economic protection.
Rather than providing a
safety net and varied forms
of economic assistance,
government would secure
heterosexuality and patriarchy--
again, largely white--
by defeating, containing, or
limiting their alleged enemies.
Civil rights, feminism,
LGBT rights, and dependency.
Breadwinner conservatism gave
such structure and coherence
to national politics
that a whole wing
of the Democratic Party
believed its only route to power
was accommodation to its terms.
The transition from the
first synthesis to the second
was possible because a
third major synthesis,
itself highly
fractured, produced
such a dramatic rupture.
We might call this simply
democratic insurgency,
and gathered under that
umbrella the various left
and progressive social movements
of the 1960s and afterward,
including especially those
concerned with racial, gender,
and sexual equity inclusion
and self-determination.
The democratic insurgency was
and is fractious and unstable,
but no more than the other two.
The salient point is that
none of the three syntheses
seems presently
capable of establishing
a new dominant
political paradigm.
Breadwinner liberalism
defined US political culture
for nearly half a century.
Breadwinner conservatism
for slightly less time.
The democratic insurgency has
been effective to be sure,
but it has not assembled
a true national coalition
and a national
electoral realignment
comparable to the other two.
Instead, what has emerged
is a fragmented electorate
organized around what
one historian has
called a volatile center.
The question remains, then--
and I will leave you with this--
whether the election cycles
of 2016, 2018, and 2020
are simply another skirmish
around that volatile center,
or a more fundamental
transformative opportunity.
My hunch is that the
answer to this question
has a great deal to do with
the direction things take
in the arena of my
previous two observations.
Thank you for allowing me to
share these thoughts with you,
and I look forward
to the discussion.
[APPLAUSE]
- So thank you so
much to all of you.
And I think this jump-starts
a really good conversation.
I have a few
questions, and so I'm
going to spearhead a
conversation amongst us first,
and then afterwards,
we will open it up
to questions from
the audience as well.
So I felt like I heard
different strains
from all of you
referring to coalitions
of both the Republican
and the Democratic Party.
And Robert, you
talked a little bit
about how some of those
coalitions have changed.
One question I have
for all of you,
actually, is that,
there's been a lot of talk
after the 2016 election about
what some folks have described
as an identity crisis.
That our politics is very
identity-driven on both
the right and the left.
And I am curious what sort
of consequences, good or bad,
that that has as we look into
2020, if we are not really
debating-- maybe we never
were, but we're certainly
no longer debating--
the marginal tax rate.
We're debating what
it means about who
gets to be an American, and
who gets to be a part of that.
And I just want to
know what effects you
think that could have as
we're heading into 2020.
- First, let me say that
there is a coalition.
We call it the new
America majority.
Our work at Democracy in Color
has taken a look at the last,
really, since people of
color have been transforming
not only the population,
but the electorate,
since 1965's Voting
Rights Act guaranteed
the rights for many people of
color coming to this country,
as well as immigration
reshaping the communities
across the nation.
We had a president,
Barack Obama,
who was elected and
re-elected on the power
of a multiracial
progressive coalition.
It is the majority of voters.
It's 23% of all white voters
and 28% of people of color.
It's not everybody
from every group.
But because our
demographics are changing,
I'm arguing that, both--
what we're seeing is a
fundamental realignment.
When I started
this conversation,
I was saying that traditional
political consultants valued
white voters above all.
But that became a limiting
factor for Democrats
unable to appeal and take
full advantage of the changing
demographics.
The fact that we have a
new American majority that
has the power to elect
Congress people, senators,
and presidents, we already know.
And that, in terms of
the population growth,
it's only going to be more so.
In terms of the eligible
population, it's more than just
about identity.
I think that we're going into
a political identity that's
intersectional and
complex, but that we
have people in this
country who can
have a single political
identity that also
allows people to come
fully as themselves
in their full identity.
And women of color do this
exceptionally well, because we,
as women--
when people say
women in politics,
they mean white women.
But we know women of color,
as you were pointing out,
vote significantly
different based on race.
We know that our race identity
helps us understand the world,
but that it is an intersectional
identity that helps to cement
a new political force.
And I really reject the
dismissal of people saying
identity politics is bad.
We all have our identities.
And we, in a
democracy, should be
able to accommodate those and
be who we are in democracy.
And identity politics,
that phrase itself
is real ugly, because it's
used to squash people who have
specific kinds of identity.
So as a black person,
it's identity politics.
But as a white person,
it's just being myself.
So I think that the
implication for 2020 for me
is that the Democrats
showed that,
by having both candidates and an
agenda that appealed to people
of different identities and
new American majority that
can actually win, or that came
close in places like Texas,
and Florida, and Arizona.
Places that Trump
won in the past.
And this new kind
of identity that's
multi-modal and
intersectional, I
believe is going to
help the Democrats to be
successful in 2020.
And the presidential
candidate who's
able to speak in that
new way is the one
that's going to be successful.
- Just a quick clarification.
I wasn't suggesting that
there's no coalition, which
I absolutely believe
fundamentally.
My point in that
last section is more
that, what we can think of as
that democratic insurgency--
which is admittedly a
very, very broad brush,
and we can disaggregate
that if we want.
It's just-- I had 10
minutes to summarize.
I'm not suggesting at all
that that's not a coalition.
I think what I was
trying to reflect on
was that, under Obama,
that coalition was not
powerful enough and successful
enough to totally transform
the political
structure and implement
its framework as the new
framework of American politics.
That's true for lots of
reasons, not all of which
are the fault of that coalition.
Some of it's political
gerrymandering,
some of it's voter
suppression, some of it's
our internal struggles
within the Democratic Party.
So it was more about--
not that there isn't
that coalition,
which is absolutely there.
It's that I don't think
we've yet seen a turn where
that coalition is
capable of establishing
a whole new paradigm
of American politics.
And maybe in a way, Aimee,
what you're saying is,
we're at a moment
when that coalition is
pushing to do just that.
- Yeah.
- Can I jump in on
identity politics too?
Just to say that,
what I see happening
is the use of identity by
political actors is changing.
And I think the 2018
midterms suggests that we
are going to see more of that.
And I say that
because identity--
as Aimee was saying,
we all have identities,
and there's increasing
evidence in political science,
and in social sciences
more generally,
that identities are central
to the way we make our votes.
And oftentimes, it's not just
now at this point in history
that identities
are driving votes,
but it has been that
way for some time.
And in fact, there's
evidence that people actually
shift their policy
positions to correspond
with their identities.
Their partisan identities,
but their partisan identities
being a basket of
identities that
fit their sense of who
they are, and what's
appropriate for someone
like themselves.
And so for me,
what this suggests
is that there's a huge
duty on our leaders
right now to make use of
identities in a positive way.
I may sound like a Pollyanna.
It may be forever
before we actually
see that kind of good behavior.
But what I'm saying
is that identities
are something that we are
proud of, and ought to be.
And they are who we are.
They help us
understand the world.
communicate with others.
And there is room
for people to be
respectful of the individual
identities that people have,
as well as help
people lead people
in seeing how those identities
can be woven together
into something like a democracy.
So I see this as a
trend that we should
expect to continue in terms
of people using identities
to divide.
But what I'm hoping
for, and calling for,
is leaders to do
something different.
- Sarah, can I ask
you specifically?
Because a couple of
political science researchers
have done some work after 2016
and said that, in some ways,
Donald Trump differed from
some prior Republicans
we saw in that he
really also appealed
to an identity politics.
And you could point
specifically to immigration.
And it was very
successful for him,
which is in part why, in
the waning days of the 2018
campaign, we saw him talk about
the caravan, and the border,
because he believed that those
were successful strategies.
- So take me back
to your question.
- Yeah.
So I guess my question
is I was asking
about the consequences
of identity politics
as we head into 2020.
- So that's a tough
one for me, because I
think he was also appealing
to a class of people that
felt like they had been spoken
over in a specific income
bracket.
And so I feel like his win
was reflective of a group
of people, and it definitely
did touch on immigration.
But can I suggest that--
there was a study done
recently, the Hidden Tribes
of America, where they
looked at all-- they broke up
the electorate and talked
about devoted conservatives,
and traditional conservatives
who are with Trump right now.
And then your progressive
activists, which are at 8%
all the way over to the left.
But there's a
politically-disengaged,
in the middle, 26%.
There are moderates
that are 15%,
and then there are
passive liberals.
And there's this
whole middle space
of people that feel like they
are not being represented
by either party.
And that's like 61%.
So I think, rather than
me talking about identity,
I would like to look
at this group of people
that don't feel represented.
And will they feel
represented coming out
of the primary
system if you have
super extremes on each side?
Or is there a middle way where--
and there's several people
circulating, talking
about independent runs.
And is there a way to
do something different
and meet this middle?
- Do you that there is?
- I do.
Depending-- if it's
super extreme candidates
on either side.
It's a very specific scenario.
It would have to be a
very specific scenario.
- Third party.
- Yeah.
Not necessary third party, or
just an independent candidate.
Because the third party
versus independent candidates,
ballot access is a big deal.
So it's harder to garner
ballot access as a third party.
It's easier to garner ballot
access as a person just running
as an independent.
- Can I just add something?
I think it's
interesting to reflect
on what I hear, in a way,
from the panel as two
different strategies.
One is what I think you just
articulated, Sarah, which
is for politicians
and political parties
to think about the existing
electorate, and to analyze it,
and to think about how
to move various pieces
within that electorate around.
And what I heard you,
Aimee, articulating--
I think-- is a different
political strategy coming out
of the Abrams campaign,
which is actually
not to accept the
electorate as it is,
but to expand it
dramatically, and to vastly
increase the political
participation of nonvoters.
And those strike me as two--
I'm not sure-- complementary,
not complementary, perhaps,
political strategies.
One accepting the
existing electorate,
and the other one saying,
we're not going to accept that.
We're going to do
something different.
Does that make any sense?
- I think it sounds like that's
exactly the conversation when
you talk to, I would say,
Republican and Democratic
strategists.
So this is the debate
that people have,
is can you turn out your base
more effectively, or can you--
and I guess my question maybe
is, if the strategy for winning
is to turn your base out,
you could make the argument
that Donald Trump did that,
and he did it very successfully
in 2016.
He did turn out people who
had historically not voted,
at least presuming that many of
the people I met at his rallies
were telling me the truth.
They will say that
they had not voted
for x number of elections.
But yet you also find
us, as a country,
I think, in a very
divided space right now.
And so I guess my
question maybe to you
all is that, even if it's
electorally successful,
what are the consequences
of doing that?
Because if you do reach out to
your base and your base alone,
you may win.
And we saw Trump win.
- I guess that the
path that the--
OK.
So I'm a partisan, so
I'm not going to talk--
the path to victory--
the Democrats lost and lost
and lost until this year
partly because that
there were people
on the ground, mostly funded
through independent efforts--
But remember, that didn't
begin until Alabama.
My organization was
involved in funding
an independent expenditure in
Alabama's special election.
Remember that?
It was December.
It was a year ago.
And there was a
child molester guy
who was running for the
GOP, disgusting dude,
and then there was a
not-that-inspiring Democrat
running.
But the Republicans
had been dominating
Alabama and that Senate
seat for 25 years.
And that's a state 24% of
the population of voters
were black.
And the independent
expenditure--
not like the Democratic Party,
and certainly not like Doug
Jones, the Democrat's campaign--
focused deeply on activating,
speaking to, and engaging
the black community
driven by black women.
There was a woman
named DeJuana Thompson,
for example, who's
one of the nation's
best top political strategists.
No one's asking her--
people are not asking her--
- I just talked to her.
- Right?
Oh, except Asma.
Except NPR.
There's LaTosha Brown,
who helped in Alabama.
And they were successful winning
that seat based on the premise
that the way that you change
the political trajectory
is you expand the electorate.
The Republicans-- it
is very sad that we're
seeing that part
of their strategy
is actually keeping it as is.
To try to compress and
suppress the number
of people who participate.
But the path to victory
for women of color
has to be through
expanding the electorate,
because the Democrats haven't
been big backers of women
of color, and we already
established that women of color
are the most progressive voters
and leaders in the country.
And so it's not like
there's been great support
from the Democratic Party.
But it is that, because
strategists like DeJuana
Thompson, people
like Andrea Mercado
in Florida, who expanded
black and brown voters
in the electorate.
They were aiming for 2% in
the primary, and they got 5%,
and then in the
general, they were
able to have such
great turnout because
of their ongoing
operation that they
were able to pass Amendment
4, which we mentioned earlier,
restored the voting rights of
people with felony records.
The same thing
happened in Arizona,
where David Garcia was a
gubernatorial candidate
at the top the ticket.
He didn't win, but Kyrsten
Sinema won as a Democrat
not because of this middle
of their white voters--
the white voters didn't
vote for Kyrsten Sinema.
And in fact, white women mostly
do not vote for white women
Democratic candidates.
And so Kirsten Cinema
won, in the end,
because of the power of the
Latinx expanded electorate.
So what I want to
say is that that
is the path forward
for Democrats for sure,
and for people who
are progressive,
to be able to bring more people
in, younger people in to vote.
And that will be the way that
we actually turn the corner.
We have an opportunity,
and it could
go a lot of different ways.
But I think that's our
bigger opportunity.
- Could--
- Sure.
- One of the things
that I think is
fascinating about what Katherine
is doing, and exciting,
and bridging the gap between
an expanded electorate and then
the current electorate
is this listening.
And I think, if you look
at President Macron--
and his numbers aren't
great right now,
but he did win because he
went out and he listened,
and his campaign actually
went out and talked to people.
So I think there's
something great here
about what you're about to do.
- Thanks.
- So I want to make sure we
have enough time for questions.
So there is a
microphone right here
in the middle of the
hallway, and please line up.
Just two quick things in
terms of asking questions.
When you do ask a question,
please identify who you are,
just so we know who you are.
And please ask a question,
because otherwise I
will have to cut you off.
So please make sure
it's a question.
All right, go ahead.
- Hi.
My name is Heather Hendershot.
I have a question for Sarah.
You identified yourself as
someone who had left the GOP.
And certainly a lot of
people have done that.
And I'm wondering
how that impacts
how we should understand
a lot of the numbers
that we see when we see a poll
that shows a high approval
rating among
Republicans for Trump.
Should we be thinking,
right, but pollsters
are talking to people
who don't identify
as Republicans anymore, and that
should impact how we understand
the number, or do
we have more people
who didn't identify as
Republicans before who
now do because they're from the
far-right, or they're populist,
and that pulls
them into the GOP?
And I don't know if that
balances out in any way.
I just don't know
what to make of it.
- So of the numbers that
I presented in particular?
Or--
- I'm just--
- Are you talking
about, in general,
Trump's approval rating
among Republicans,
how accurate is that?
- Yes.
But any other numbers about
Republican feelings about x.
I'm wondering if we have
to say, well, that's not--
- Is it really reflective
of the Republican Party,
and conservatives, and
the Trumpification--
because there is
that new GOP base,
which I don't feel like is
reflective of the Republican
Party.
My parents still
identify as Republicans.
They don't like Donald Trump.
So the numbers are
tough, but I think--
they're tough with
the approval rating.
But the approval rating numbers
that I gave were nationwide.
The 41% to the 43%.
So I think some people--
and I think this is true
of the 2016 election--
are quietly approving what
he's doing, and may not
be identifying that to you and
me as people, but are saying,
the economy's fine.
Brett Kavanaugh
just got nominated--
so I think there's
a quiet acceptance.
Does that makes sense?
- Yeah.
- Sadly.
- I think so.
Yeah.
Thank you, thank you.
- It's not satisfying, is it?
- No.
Yeah, I know.
[CHUCKLING]
- Hi.
I'm Kathryn Sikkink,
and I'm a faculty member
at the Kennedy School and
a Radcliffe professor.
In terms of expanding
the electorate,
we haven't heard much about
the youth vote and the college
vote.
And we're here on campus.
And so we know that youth
voters and college voters
vote at some of the lowest
levels of any people
in the electorate.
I've also heard-- but I
have not had confirmed--
that there was about a 10%
increase in this midterm as
compared to the last midterm.
So could you just
tell us a little more
what we know about the
youth vote, and the college
vote in the midterms?
- Sure.
To your question
about the numbers,
there are unconfirmed
numbers at this point.
I know CIRCLE over
at Tufts University
does really good analysis
on the youth voter turnout,
and did find the estimates
to be about 10% higher.
I think we'll get a
better sense of that
once the census numbers come
out, which are self-reported.
But overall, I feel like most
people will say confidently,
youth voter turnout was up.
I think the conundrum people
run into a little bit is--
Florida's a really
good case study.
I talked to both
Democrats and Republicans
who'll both admit and say
youth voter turnout was up.
But the problem is everybody's
voter turnout was up.
I mean, the problem for
Democrats, in that situation,
was that, as a result,
there was expected
to be a huge uptick
because of the results
of the school shooting
at Parkland and whatnot,
and they did not see
that manifest itself
fully in the general election.
And Florida, I think, is a
really good case study of that,
because you have polar
opposite extremes in terms
of the age electorate there.
- Thank you.
- Hi.
I'm Julio Ricardo Varela.
I'm a journalist and a proud
alumnus of the college of 1990.
Asma, you mentioned Florida.
And I'm glad, because I
wanted to know, particularly
from Robert and Aimee--
because the notion
of the multiracial,
multi-ethnic coalition, no one
used Florida as an example.
And actually, is
Florida the national--
are we going to become
Florida as a nation?
And I say that because--
and I point to your side,
Robert, about the Latina vote.
Black women, totally Democratic.
Latina women, 27%
voted for Donald Trump,
or voted Republican.
And also, if you look
at the numbers in 2016--
and Florida's the perfect case,
because when you have DeSantis
telling people that Gillum's
going to turn Florida
into Venezuela, then you have
one extreme to the other,
and it kind of speaks
to Sarah's point too.
So I'd love to hear what you
guys think about Florida,
because it kind of goes against
the winning-is-losing type.
Or what do you think?
Because it's not so cut and dry.
So I'm curious to--
- Can I just give
you a quick summary?
Just because I
actually specifically
looked at the Florida Latino
population just a couple
of weeks ago, actually, to
answer that specific question.
And I think that, in Florida,
there were two really
interesting dynamics.
One is Rick Scott, who was
running for the Senate seat,
explicitly courted the
Hispanic vote in a way
that I would argue
other Republicans ought
to pay attention to.
It was highly successful.
- And the Puerto Rican
vote in central Florida.
- Exactly.
He was doing Spanish
language ads.
He taught himself
Spanish through an aide.
So that was one factor.
The other people
pointed me towards
is that DeSantis, who is now
going to be the governor,
his running mate
was a very popular
Cuban-American legislator,
and she heavily
focused on upping
that population.
And so as a result,
I think many people
thought Barack Obama did
pretty well with parts
of the Cuban population in
Florida that seemed to revert.
I don't know if revert's the
right-- because who knows?
Maybe these were
different Cuban voters.
It was an older electorate.
But I think that that's
a really good question,
because it showed,
to me, inroads
that Republicans have been
able to make in that state.
But please--
- I'm curious what you
guys have about this.
Thank you.
- Yeah.
I will say-- when you say,
is the country become--
there's no monolith
among Latinos.
I don't have to tell you that.
- [INAUDIBLE]
[CHUCKLING]
- What the strategists
need to know about what
motivates Puerto Rican voters--
200,000 additional were
added to the voter rolls
since the hurricane--
is different from Tejanos,
different from Mexicanos,
different from people from
Colombia or Central America.
It's different.
Dominicans.
So there's no monolith.
And before Trump
came along, the GOP
was actually making some
significant inroads,
and had funded
programs where we had
people in the center of
the highest population--
Latinos in Texas,
and in Arizona,
New Mexico, and
California-- where
they were running voter
engagement, because every day,
in California, 7,000 Latinos
become eligible to vote.
18-year-olds.
It's a number that the GOP, at
one point, was deeply invested
and speaking to.
And then Trump came along.
And Trump messed up--
despite what
happened in Florida,
Trump messed up the GOP plans
to really engage and bring it.
So in Florida specifically,
the GOP has won by 1%.
1%.
Out of 15 million voters,
it's such a small number.
And that number,
although Andrew Gillum--
who's a gubernatorial
candidate--
wasn't able to overcome that,
the Democrats weren't able
to overcome that, there
are efforts on the ground--
I mentioned Andrea Mercado
from an organization
called the New Florida Majority.
And that is not a one-and-done
type of organization.
It's a statewide
organization that
continues to build and
outreach among the Latinx
and black communities.
And the gains that
they saw in terms
of turnout and engagement,
if they're fully funded
and continue on
this path, you're
going to see even stronger
Latinx turnout come 2020.
- The only thing I would add--
I agree with all of that.
And I would just add that
the new American majority--
as well, I would say
Asian-Americans-- are also
a slightly more complicated
demographic in-group in terms
of its voter preference.
So there are absolutely
important distinctions,
and differences, and values,
and political leanings
within that new
American majority
that politicians who
are emerging to lead it
are going to have to
be paying attention to.
So that's-- I think I'm just
reiterating, essentially,
what you said, but.
- Yeah.
- Hi.
My name's David Layman,
member of the general public.
[CHUCKLING]
- That's a good title.
- No affiliation with Harvard.
So my question is
really a generalization
of the first questioner's
question, which
is, do you trust the polls?
All of you have talked about
the changing demographics
of the electorate.
A footnote on one
of the charts said
based on 600 of likely voters.
As it's all changing,
how do the pollsters
know who the likely voters are?
Because it's changing,
as you speak,
through deliberate
action, and through
the action of the politicians.
- We got it all wrong in 2016.
- Well, everyone's like,
remember when Alexandria
Ocasio-Cortez won?
[GASPS]
What a shock!
She beat 10-term Crowley.
It was out of the blue.
No it wasn't, buddy.
Because she had a strategy
of expanding the electorate,
and the pollsters missed it.
And they missed Andrew
Gillum in the primary.
He was the only non-millionaire
in a field of five.
And for sure, they
thought he had no chance.
Black guy who's
mayor of Tallahassee
trying to run for governor.
No way he's getting
through the primary.
And then when he was
successful, they were shocked.
Pollsters had no idea.
So what the pollsters
we work with,
like Celinda Lake and PPP--
these are Democratic
Party pollsters--
they have to change
their strategy
to be able to figure out
what's really going on.
If they're doing
calling, for example--
people don't have home phones.
Just the methodology
in that in order
to figure out what voters
think has to change.
And that five-out-of-five-- what
they call the regular voters--
they're going to have to
expand who they ask for.
These are eligible,
maybe registered.
Maybe they've never voted
for president before.
They need to ask
that person too.
And in particular races,
and districts and states,
they need to prioritize,
particularly what
women of color are doing
on the Democratic side,
because that's an indicator
of how, in the primaries,
things will go.
- I'm going to jump in
on this one too, since--
I study public opinion, so I
use polling data quite a bit.
But I think it's
safe to say there's
a vast over-reliance on
polls as a measure of what
public opinion is.
And it's our best-known
way of capturing
what a broad population
thinks at a moment in time.
But I think 2016--
I don't think it was as
much of a wake-up call
as it should have been, but
it was a wake-up call to say,
public opinion is
complex, and there's
a lot that's going on
that we don't understand,
and our current methods
aren't adequate for the task.
- Thank you very much.
- Hi.
Tom [INAUDIBLE].
You seem to have looked at this
from every perspective except
the president's.
When you look at Obama's
first midterm in 2010,
Democrats lost 63 seats,
which is about 40%
more than Republicans lost.
They also lost six Senate seats,
while the Republicans actually
had a net gain.
We also saw that when
the president personally
campaigned for candidates,
such as was mentioned--
Marsha Blackburn and
Hyde-Smith, as well as for Kemp,
and DeSantis, and Hawley,
and Braun, and many others--
they did quite well.
So the president's still a
very powerful campaigner.
We've also, of course, seen that
there were other factors that
came into this, such as the
Kavanaugh hearings, that
mobilized the base of
the Republican Party.
And it looks like
the president still
has a lot of cause for optimism,
because the Democrats also--
even though they
lost the House, this
is going to be a
ready-made excuse
to explain why his
agenda won't pass,
whereas he had a harder time
explaining when they controlled
both houses of the Congress.
So the president still has
a lot of cause for optimism,
doesn't he?
- Yeah.
I think that was
Sarah's point, right?
- That was my point.
- Yeah.
Thank you, though.
- Yes.
- Hi.
My name's Monty Allen, and
I go to things like this
as much as I can,
and I have to say,
this has been a really,
really good one.
Thank you all for that.
- I like that.
[APPLAUSE]
I like that comment.
- I really care about
what happens in 2020.
And I want the Democrats
to just prevail.
And so what's been
really insightful to me--
and I thank you for
presenting it-- is identifying
constituencies where
it's strategically
really wise for Democratic
candidates to invest.
Expanding the electorate.
I was heartened by the vote
in Florida that expanded
the vote to former-- to felons.
And obviously, there's
some constituencies
where there's no point.
It would be a fool's errand
to try to change their minds.
But I think there's a large--
I'm particularly interested
in the work that you're doing,
Dr. Cramer, because
I think there's
a large part of our society
who have been left behind
by the evolutionary
trajectory of our economy.
And along with it is identity
things, as you mentioned.
And it's a loss of
sense of your status
in our society,
your personal honor,
apart from or in addition
to your economic struggles
that go along with
those economic trends.
So I think the listening
project that you're initiating
is maybe the key to
helping Democrats
know how to identify and address
the issues that resulted in--
- Can I just ask
just real quick?
Sorry, do you have a question?
Just because you have
like 30 seconds--
- Yeah.
OK.
Well, Staten is a
really great case,
because it used to be Democrat.
It used to be
really progressive,
and now it has
gone the other way.
So what do you
think you can learn
that would be good counsel
for Democrats addressing
that population?
- Well, we're hoping
that the project helps
politicians of all
stripes better understand
the people that they represent.
Because one thing-- probably
goes without saying,
but politicians these days
spend so much time raising money
that they actually don't
have the luxury of inviting
themselves into conversations
in gas stations, like I do,
which is a real shame.
So we're hoping that it
lends insights to politicians
of a variety of parties.
- Great.
Thank you.
I know we're
running out of time,
but why don't we take just
this one last question?
I apologize.
- I'm Lewis [INAUDIBLE].
My question goes to economics.
The last two
election cycles have
occurred during a period of
expansion in the economy.
Not all people have
participated in that.
That led to resentment.
It's increasingly
likely we're going
to see a major economic
disruption in the next two
years.
The closing of
General Motors plants
are just the first two steps in
a radical change in our economy
that will occur.
What impact do you think this
probable economic downturn
is going to have on
the next election,
since the last two
elections were fought,
whatever people said in
an expanding economy,
and that's highly
unlikely for 2020?
- It's hard to know.
People are talking about
a recession in two years,
but when will people
start feeling that?
So I think that it's important--
- Yeah.
And not to cut you off--
- No, no, no, go.
- I think there are a lot of
people who work full-time who
are still poor.
And that sense of
not being heard,
that's why I think
there's such momentum
around a $15 minimum wage.
Even a lot of Democrats
have rejected that notion
as too crazy.
And now, that is part of the
broad-based platform that's
accepted that minimum wage
won't destroy economy,
but will help people
who work, as part
of this near-full employment,
to be able to support themselves
and their families.
I think that that's
one of the big things.
We have a candidate I just read
about, last name Yang, who's
running his presidential
primary campaign
on universal basic income.
We have a mayor, Michael Tubbs,
in Stockton, California, who
is doing an experimental
pilot project
on universal basic
income to see if that
could be part of the solution.
He's getting big
backing from tech.
So I just want to say that we're
going to see all kinds of ideas
to deal with the economic
problems that we have.
We're going to see
those manifest in some
of the campaigns coming up.
We'll know everybody that's
in the field in eight weeks.
Everyone who's
running for president.
Because we look
back, Barack Obama
announced January 18 before--
it's coming up.
And I think the economic
solution, particularly
around the working
poor, is going
to be one of the
central issues that
the presidential candidates
on the Democratic side
are going to have to address.
- We have gone over by a
few minutes, so I am-- well,
I guess-- what do we have?
Are you the last question?
Yeah, why don't we
take that real quick?
- I'm sorry.
I really would love to hear--
and Katherine actually
commented about the time
candidates need to
spend fundraising.
My question is Citizens
United and money spent.
And I would be curious
to know if there
was anything significant
about either 2016 and '18,
but compared to prior elections,
and/or special interest money.
- The elections are
getting more expensive.
- Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
- Period.
- I would read former
Senator Dingell's article
that came out today.
And he was like, I was in the
Senate longer than everybody,
so I'm going to tell
you what we need to do.
One was abolish the
Senate, for your reasons.
Because he says, undemocratic.
You get these little states.
I'm from California.
40 million people.
We only have two senators,
and so does Rhode Island.
Now, why is that fair?
So he says that.
But he also says, publicly
finance every single campaign,
so that we take money
out so that we bring
the public back into service.
I like that idea.
It's a good article.
- Great.
Thank you so much to
all of our panelists.
[APPLAUSE]